[Music]
immigration reform is a hot topic in the
news again and some politicians are
actually saying americans shouldn't be
allowed to vote unless they can pass the
same naturalization test that immigrants
need to pass in order to become citizens
sure okay it's very controversial i've
said this before i want to say it again
i personally think it's a great idea i
do i think it'll be very good for the
country and to prove it i'm going to
once again be the only late night talk
show host to take the u.s citizen test
on the air with some help from my pal
andy i want to do this
now
we've done this before and this is a
particularly tough batch of questions
i'm not scared let's do it all right all
right put your glasses on grandma okay
oh there they are hey ben franklin all
right here we go
what do we call the first ten amendments
to the constitution the bill of rights
if both the president and vice president
can no longer serve who becomes
president the speaker of the house
name three u.s mayors bloomberg virgosa
and
mcgees do the red stripes on the flag
represent bacon strips
and what do the white stripes on the
flag represent uncooked bacon strips
in which american institution can you
find mickey mouse donald duck and buzz
lightyear the george w bush presidential
library
what's the most endangered species in
america the non-obese mississippian
merged three presidents last names to
make one porn name johnson van johnson
list eight euphemisms for money bucks
clams moula simoleons dough greenbacks
cashola and sweet sweet wallet juice
what's the most popular drink in
connecticut the repressed caucasian
recreational use of marijuana is legal
in washington state colorado and your
dressing room
if a supreme court justice marries darth
vader and opened a potato-based party
food business on the side it would be
called ruth bader vader's all-tater
catering
okay
complete the following phrase
fill in the blank
true or false all right yeah
all right i'm going to name an american
novelist you have to tell me his
nickname for his own penis
herman melville the white whale
ernest hemingway the movable feast
f scott fitzgerald great gatsby
kurt vonnegut breakfast of champions
stephen king the dark tower
john grisham the firm
biggie biggie biggie can't you see
sometimes your words just hypnotize me
and i just love your flashy ways yes
that's why they're broken you're so paid
in the time we've spent taking this test
there have been uh 14 itunes software
updates 41 nfl player arrests and four
new fast and furious movies
summarize the neutrality act of 1794.
the neutrality act of 1794 made it
illegal for foreign war vessels to
outfit in american waters it set a
three-mile territorial limited sea and
also forbade an american to wage war
against any country at peace with the
united states declaring that if any
person shall within the territory or
jurisdiction the united states begin or
set a foot on provider or prepare the
means for any military expeditionary
enterprise against the territorial
dominions of any foreign prince of state
of whom the united states has at peace
the person would be guilty of a
misdemeanor
wow
and finally
where's the party and who's invited in
my pants and everyone all right
[Applause]
we did it you did it